joining us now on the phone is George
Washington University law professor
Jonathan Turley who's been watching
these events unfold tonight professor
Turley your reaction to the firing of
Andrew McCabe two days before his 50th
birthday when his pension would have
kicked in after 20 years of service at
the FBI professor well I'm not surprised
by the decision some of us said it was
very likely that he would be fired the
reason is that this is an exceedingly
rare recommendation coming from the
Office Professional Responsibility it's
it's virtually unheard of for someone
who held the position of McCabe so it
was very unlikely in my view that Jeff
sessions would not follow that career
advice he followed that advice in his
own recusal he yielded to career
officers who had recommended that course
so I didn't die I've said before I
thought it was very likely that he would
do precisely what what he did tonight
what is I think a more difficult
question they'll be presented for the
Justice Department is how they will go
from here because the suggestion is that
the Inspector General found that McCabe
intentionally misled their investigators
that's almost indistinguishable from
what they charged Michael Flynn with
exactly good point
so the question that's going to be on
the table here is one of continuity
Flynn that was accused of lying about
not the meeting with the Russians he
apparently admitted that but simply
talking about sanction action the
meeting yeah the meeting with the
Russians was not illegal in this case
McCabe is accused of misleading
investigators on something that was a
violation of federal rules and so I
think the question will be raised as
well is this simply a matter of a
pension or because for Flynn it was a
matter of prison yeah I can't be that
yeah 18 USC 1001 and now it looks like
Michael Flynn might not have had that
rec was an intent to lie